[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous Bienvenue
c'est sens public votre rendez-vous de
débat et de reportage sur Public Sénat
vous le savez la promesse et dans le
titre de l'émission donnée du sens à
l'actualité vous proposez des clés de
compréhension des mutations de notre
société et l'actualité de ce 9 mai c'est
le défilé militaire à Moscou pour les
cérémonies commémorant la victoire
contre l'Allemagne nazie la lumière
Poutine qui s'adresse à son peuple mais
aussi et surtout au monde en s'affirmant
une nouvelle fois comme le leader d'un
pays attaqué par l'Occident dans quel
état se trouve l'armée russe avant la
contre-offensive ukrainienne le chef des
milices Wagner qui accuse aujourd'hui
les hauts gradé de tromper Poutine
est-il devenu incontrôlable réponse
juste après ses titres et puis pour
notre second thème volontairement décalé
de l'actualité du jour on se demande si
la France va suivre l'exemple de
l'Espagne pionnière dans la prise en
charge des règles douloureuses
nous sommes le premier pays d'Europe à
réglementer une incapacité temporaire
payée intégralement par l'État pour les
règles douloureuses incapacitante plus
besoin d'aller travailler en ayant mal
plus besoin de prendre des pilules avant
d'aller au travail et de devoir cacher
le fait que nous avons mal et que nous
sommes incapables de travailler ces
jours-là faut-il instaurer un congé
menstruel comment ça se passe dans les
collectivités où les entreprises qui ont
déjà mis en place ce système pourquoi
les règles incapacitantes notamment
l'endométriose sont-elles toujours aussi
mal à diagnostiquer réponse dans 45
minutes mais d'abord comment le chef du
Kremlin veut faire oublier son
incapacité à vaincre l'Ukraine
l'essentiel de son discours sur la Place
Rouge avec Jonathan du priez
sous les yeux de Vladimir Poutine
l'armée russe défile pour le 78e
anniversaire de la victoire sur
l'Allemagne nazie mais en plein bourbier
ukrainien les célébrations ont pris un
tour plus modeste qu'à la coutumée sans
char et sans para aérienne le maître du
Kremlin se Sète en difficulté sur le
théâtre ukrainien mais tente de
convaincre ses compatriotes qu'une
victoire prochaine est encore possible
regardez monsieur
nous sommes fiers des participants à
l'opération militaire spéciale de tous
ceux qui se battent sur la ligne de
front qui apporte leur soutien sous le
feu qui secourent les blessés rien n'est
plus importants actuellement que votre
tâche militaire pour la Russie pour nos
valeurs aux forces armées pour la
victoire pour
seulement 15 mois après le début de
l'invasion en Ukraine les défaites
militaires russes se sont accumulés au
prix de lourdes pertes humaines et le
front s'est figé le long du Dombas très
disputé la ville de barmouth fait
toujours l'objet d'apre au combat et les
milliers de mercenaires du groupe Wagner
ne semble pas infléchir le cours de la
guerre pire leur chef mène des charges
de plus en plus virulente contre l'armée
russe l'Ukraine dit clairement que la
contre-offensive se fera sur le terrain
pas à la télévision alors qu'en Russie
tout le monde pense que nous devrions
tout faire à la télévision et célébrer
le 9 mai ce jour de la victoire c'est la
victoire de nos aïeux nous n'en n'avons
pas mérité ne serait-ce qu'une fraction
de son côté l'Ukraine continue à
afficher sa détermination face à
l'envahisseur russe volo dix mirzelenski
a affirmé vouloir infliger à la Russie
la même défaite que celle qu'on connaît
les nazis il exhorte dans le même temps
les Européens à accélérer les livraisons
de munitions d'artillerie et je crois
tout de suite mes invités bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes enseignants en
conflit sécurité international à
Sciences Po et co-auteur de ce livre Le
Pacte des autocrates publié chez Robert
Lafont Patricia lemonnière bonsoir
Patricia bienvenue grand reporter
spécialiste des relations
internationales Jérôme klech bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes enseignant en
prospective et stratégie à Sciences Po
Paris et vous publiez ce livre la
prospective stratégique qui va sortir le
25 mai si je suis le 24 mai le 24 va
hier soir on précis aux éditions Hermann
merci Elisa parce qu'ils bonsoir Émilie
bienvenue vous êtes spécialiste en
communication politique et éditorialiste
pour sens public bon la Russie elle
célèbre toujours je le rappelle la
victoire contre l'Allemagne Nazi le 9
mai et pas le 8 mai comme comme nous
c'est normalement l'occasion d'une
grande démonstration de force Julien
terrain est-ce que là vous diriez c'est
plutôt une démonstration en demi teinte
pour planer Poutine
ça se veut une démonstration de force et
vous avez tout à fait raison de
d'indiquer que par rapport aux autres
fois c'est une démonstration plutôt de
manque de force si vous me permettez
l'expression oui parce que il y a moins
d'hommes alors c'est quand même
substantiel il y a 8000 hommes je crois
à la place de 11000 mais surtout le
manque de matériel
le puccinisme n'est pas une idéologie
c'est une méthode c'est une méthode
fondée sur un mythe le culte de la force
la force représentative de l'homme vous
connaissez certainement vous avez
certainement analysé tout ça bien mieux
que moi mais aussi la force brute la
force militaire la force conventionnelle
la force en nombre et en type et en
avant cette technologie dématériels
militaires c'est une grand-mère qui
donne lieu chaque année à faire ce genre
de choses et là c'est l'inverse
c'est-à-dire qu'on s'aperçoit qu'il n'y
a pas de char d'assaut logique parce
qu'ils sont censés être sur le front
mais enfin normalement je vous rappelle
que c'était une opération qui devait
durer deux jours qui s'appelle une
opération spéciale qui disait qu'il sera
à Kiev très rapidement voir avant nous
expliquer que Berlin pouvait être
conquis très rapidement également enfin
je veux dire pour l'instant on voit plus
de temps et moins de soldats et pas de
force aérienne au dessus de Moscou avec
des drones qui sont allés s'écraser sur
le toit du Kremlin quel conçoit la
raison ça ne donne pas du tout la même
impression je pense qu'il faut y voir
deux choses effectivement une question
capacitaire engagée sur le terrain et
peut-être aussi un changement de ligne
du Kremlin de dire nous sommes une
nation assiégée ils le disent plusieurs
fois il a dit plusieurs fois dans son
discours il y a beaucoup d'éléments
symboliques comme c'était ma
générationnel qu'on voyait juste pendant
son discours avec la génération d'avant
qui s'était battue a priori et puis la
génération des cadets juste au dessus
qui est censé prendre la relève Patricia
Lemonnier effectivement quand il déclare
l'avenir de la Russie est en jeu dans ce
conflit c'est l'une des phrases qu'on a
qu'on a retenu est-ce que voilà est-ce
que c'est pas ainsi en creux un signe de
faiblesse de dire ça c'est
en tout cas l'avenir est en jeu pour ça
fait partie de
ça ce que je trouve qui était
intéressant dans ce discours c'est
d'abord il avait peut-être un côté plus
solennel que celui de l'année dernière
peut-être plus grave plus
plus concernant enfin plus voilà plus
grave j'ai trouvé et puis surtout il
employait des mots qu'il n'avait jamais
employé il dit quand même que l'Occident
a déclenché une guerre donc
c'était un terme que l'on n'avait pas
employé donc si l'Occident qui est en
plus
défini comme
déclenchant des coups d'État et
oppressant le peuple allant à l'encontre
du peuple donc dans ce discours outre le
fait qu'il a toute une partie qui est
vis-à-vis des soldats qui se battent et
ça aussi c'est un peu nouveau dans son
discours il
interpelle encore une nouvelle fois j'ai
envie de dire parce que le sud global en
fait on y reviendra on y reviendra parce
qu'on va écouter cette extrémité
discours
il utilise le mot guerre qui est
peut-être à ses yeux aussi une façon de
justifier ces difficultés parce que si
l'Occident est en guerre c'est autre
chose qu'une simple opération spéciale
dont on vient de parler contre des
Ukrainiens on laisse quand Poutine il y
a eu un certain nombre de commémorations
qui ont été annulés aujourd'hui alors la
justification c'est la menace théorie
c'est effectivement il y a eu l'attaque
de drones il y a quelques jours mais
est-ce qu'il y a effectivement un risque
à faire défiler trop ou plus de soldats
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas s'il y avait
un risque mais il y a un risque de ne
pas être au bon endroit au bon moment
certains commentateurs sur ce plateau ou
sur d'autres on dit que le 9 mai
pourrait être le moment de la
contre-offensive
hérité c'est heureux personne ne sait
exactement quand tu auras lieu la
contrevancie ou peut-être certains états
majeurs mais en tout cas pas le grand
public le but d'une contre-offensive
pour que ça puisse réussir c'est d'abord
la surprise l'effet de surprise donc il
faut être au bon endroit au bon moment
donc qui est une certaine réserve sur
les commémorations sur les défilés ça ne
doit pas étonner voilà après ce qui doit
prévaloir dans ces commémorations c'est
évidemment la dimension cognitive de la
guerre cette guerre informationnelle qui
fait rage et j'allais dire le fait qu'on
en parle aujourd'hui est en illustration
flagrante et donc pour être rendez vous
de cette guerre cognitive
il faut avoir des messages à véhiculer
et ces messages il faut qu'ils soient
bien ciblés et qui a une cible bien
entendu cette cible là elle est
évidemment intérieure il s'agit de
conserver l'adhésion du peuple russe on
peut pas parler d'adhésion mais en tout
cas de ne pas se Lallier davantage il y
a une mole adhésion il y a une forme de
résignation le peuple russe par certains
endroits à certains endroits certains
moments s'est exprimé en disant qu'il ne
voyait pas
ces mobilisations et cette guerre se
déroulait dans ces modalités comme il
faudrait mais n'a pas remis en cause le
bien fondé de cette guerre et l'idée
c'est dans la durée de conserver cette
adhésion et puis il y a évidemment la
dimension extérieure ce Sud globale vous
le parliez ou il faut alimenter le
contre discours selon lequel ce serait
l'OTAN qui oui en ces tendant
l'Occident a attaqué la Russie mais
c'est voilà
plusieurs fois depuis début de la guerre
dans une large partie du monde mais car
à cet égard la représentation du réel
qui fait vérité la représentation du
réel elle est reprise par une bonne
partie de pays qui qui se restent
conciliant à l'égard de la réussite à
l'Assemblée Générale des Nations mais
vous l'avez vous avez évoqué l'un et
l'autre l'une et l'autre se cette
extrait du discours de du président
russe on l'écoute effectivement il dit
la civilisation est à nouveau à un
tournant on écoute cette extrême
la civilisation est de nouveau à un
tournant une guerre a été lancée contre
notre patrie mais nous avons lutté
contre le terrorisme international nous
protégerons également le peuple du
don-basse nous assurons notre propre
sécurité
alors je reprends vos arguments à l'une
et à l'autre vous vouliez prendre la
parole Émilie rapidement alors allez-y
rapidement mais j'ai l'impression qu'en
effet il y a quand même un glissement
dans le storytelling que raconte Poutine
depuis le début parce que maintenant
c'est une guerre la Russie alors que
depuis le début en effet il parlait
d'une opération spéciale pour aller
défendre le don-basse contre les nazis
donc il y a un glissement et en face on
a quand même un Zélande ski qui reste
lui sur une communication qui est hyper
constante on a toujours vu depuis le
début c'est le ski en selfie vous
souvenez le premier selfie dans la rue
avec son équipe déjà entri et il a une
communication comme ça toujours la même
quand il a quelques victoires en quelque
sorte du soutien des européens ou des
occidentaux il la joue modeste il la
joue toujours sur la même ligne il la
joue assez humble il l'ajouterait
demandeur il a multiplié les visions
partout à l'ONU à l'Union européenne et
il adapte son discours au pays ou à
l'institution à laquelle s'adresse en
effet chez Poutine c'est très important
la communication ça fait partie aussi de
sa guerre et là il y a une espèce de
déséquilibre qui commence à à agir on
verra alors moi je reprends le fil
effectivement de Poutine en chef du
Grand Sud en quelque sorte est-ce que
finalement Patricia Lemonia le le 14
mois de guerre n'ont pas plutôt affaibli
dans
les 14 mois de guerre on
regroupé finalement autour de lui en
fait ce n'est pas tant ces prestations
et ce qu'il dit qui compte c'est cette
révolte et ce discours contre l'Occident
c'est ça qui marche en fait ce n'est pas
ce qui se passe sur le terrain il a
réussi victoire militaire à mettre en
avant il joue ce rôle il a réussi à
finalement agrégé autour de lui tout le
mécontentement qui est là et qui gonfle
et parce qu'il faut bien trouver des
exutoirs et par exemple la crise au
niveau du blé etc c'était la faute de
l'Occident
le pétrole c'est la faute de l'Occident
enfin tout les non succès économiques
presque la dette c'est la faute de
l'Occident alors qu'on sait qu'en
Afrique la dette la Chine a un grand
rôle dans dans justement la création de
la dette et bien il arrive à agréger ce
mécontentement et on le voit très bien
il va y avoir la réunion des BRICS qui
va se passer Inde
Chine et Afrique du Sud je les ai tous
et donc la Réunion a lieu en Afrique du
Sud et bien il y a plus d'une dizaine de
pays africains qui veulent dont certains
Africains qui veulent adhérer au bricks
tout ça parce que ça rassemble ce
discours finalement qui antioxydantal et
du côté de l'occident il n'y a pas de
réflexion je trouve là-dessus et donc
Poutine en profite est-ce que vous êtes
tous d'accord là-dessus sur le fait que
finalement alors qu'on peut dire qu'il y
a eu des erreurs stratégiques de Poutine
que les résultats de la guerre le le
fragilisent que bien sûr enfin bon sans
parler des horreurs et des cris mais que
malgré tout ce son rôle diplomatique
international sort renforcé est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ces idées ça pas
été facile au début mais il est en train
de revenir il a installé des circuits
alternatifs pour nourrir son économie en
utilisant des sociétés écran dans
plusieurs pays il a accru ses échanges
économiques avec la Chine et l'Inde sur
les sur les énergies il continue à
exporter des armements même c'est
compliqué
il se fait le porte-voix de de plusieurs
pays il a deux trois victoires qu'on
voit
je sais pas si vous avez remarqué on a
vu Nicole pachinian le Premier ministre
arménien présent dans les tribunes je
vous rappelle que Vladimir Poutine a
lâché Nicole pachinian qui n'aime pas du
tout il a fait c'est quelqu'un qui vient
de la société sur les cafés campagne
contre la corruption c'est à dire en
gros le Navalny arménien il a lâché
pendant la guerre d'une agorne au
carambar au point de ça de vraiment
qu'il y ait une partie de la population
arménienne qui qui soit avant mécontacte
son donations qui sont très proches
historiquement nicole passionale est là
ça c'est une victoire diplomatique vous
voyez il dit que tous les pays dans son
discours a dit que tous les pays de
l'Organisation du Traité de sécurité
collective qui est un peu en gros pour
faire simple un peu l'OTAN post-sophie
qui réunit la Russie et les pays d'Asie
centrale
sont présents c'est le cas effectivement
en Afrique au Moyen-Orient
avec la Chine avec l'Inde il y a des
partenariats qui se sont en train de se
créer l'Occident est passablement divisé
sur la stratégie amener
je crois qu'il est en train de revenir
en force et qu'il faut pas imaginer que
pour lui perdre militairement en fait il
est en train de perdre relativement de
manière très relative d'ailleurs il a
quand même encore gagné du territoire
par rapport à février 2022 mais même si
perdait en Ukraine il est en train
d'étendre le SCOP alors en termes de
domaine de guerre comme vous le disiez
de manière sur la guerre cognitive la
guerre internationale qui s'appelle
en russe donc c'est des informationsnel
et également en guerre politique et il y
a tout un tas de je vais pas vous
embêter avec des choses académiques mais
il y a tout un tas de théories y compris
en Russie qui sont travaillés
aujourd'hui pour maîtriser la population
c'est-à-dire vous et moi y compris ici
en diffusant des messages et et de cette
manière là il est en train d'étendre le
message et il est en train d’étendre son
influence dans le monde aussi pour
transformer leur intentionnelle il a le
soutien de Pékin ouvert ouvert sur cette
question là
[Musique]
évident bon et c'est réciproque donc
pour lui si vous voulez pour asseoir son
son autorité à l'intérieur il faut
véritablement surfer sur une certaine
finalement force retrouver à l'extérieur
et je souscris entièrement à ce qui a
été dit s'agissant de cette capacité à
cristalliser le ressentiment
occidental qu'à nourrit le sud global
d'ailleurs anti
can nourrit le ressentiment
antioxydantal et qui finalement trouve à
ce cristalliser à travers cette formule
le sud global ça émergé récemment et ça
a émergé au moment où justement ce
ressentiment ces cristalliser ça veut
dire qu'à chaque fois que pardon nous
interrompage à chaque fois que Blagnac
Poutine reçoit un chef d'État étranger
où se rend à une un sommet type brique
etc on sait pas si pourra se rendre chez
les briques
ça lui sert aussi sur la scène
intérieure c'est ce que c'est ce que
vous dire les deux sont encore
correspondance d'une façon quand il y a
une guerre qui est lancée il faut
toujours s'interroger sur les raisons
intérieures typiquement si on prend le
cas de la Chine Taïwan n'a jamais été
autant d'actualité que depuis que
shishin pin lui-même a été constesté
suite aux mesures anti-covid bon il y a
toujours ce besoin en fait de se
rassurer à l'extérieur quand on est
discuté disputé à l'intérieur et
réciproquement voyez mais le message de
Vladimir Poutine à l'occasion de ce 9
mai il est essentiellement tourné
tourné vers l'extérieur alors si on
cherche il y en a pas beaucoup mais des
voix discordantes en Russie alors il y
en a une on va essayer d'analyser parce
qu'il y a une première lecture un peu
basique consiste à dire voilà il y a eu
dans les brancards c'est celle des
guenies prigognes quel chef du groupe
paramilitaire Wagner il choisit lui
aussi ce 9 mai pour publier une vidéo
sur le réseau social telegramme
le 9 mai l'une des unités du ministère
de la Défense a abandonné ses positions
à fui l'un de nos flancs
alors dans les titres je posais la
question est-ce qu'il est devenu un
contrôlable volontairement je sais que
je force un peu le trait mais à quoi il
joue comment vous l'analysez vous
Patricia lemonniere cette ces prises de
ce n'est pas la première c'est prise de
parole de trilogie alors bon
il force le trait chaque fois et on a vu
ces dernières reconnaissances cette
dernière son avant-dernière déclaration
où là il est Ruquet pratiquement avec
des mots qui sont pour nous d'une
extrême vulgarité mais qui sont dans le
discours classique finalement des
responsables où ils sont on joue de la
vulgarité beaucoup dans les discours
officiels russes qu'est-ce qu'ils
cherchent ils cherchent simplement je
crois à se maintenir c'est un homme qui
est un homme d'affaires c'est un homme
de qui veut de pouvoir aussi mais qui
dit et qui cherche à maintenir
totalement une position il pouvait avoir
un manque d'armes si on ne sait même pas
si c'est
très difficile d'avoir la vérité par
exemple là quand il dit il y a eu des
troupes qui sont partis ces fameuses
troubles dont ils parlent ce sont des
unités spéciales en théorie qui sont
positionnées là de l'armée russe
je vois mal je les vois mal partir si
elles sont parties c'est donc sur ordre
et donc ça souligne encore une nouvelle
fois cette fameuse dissonance qu'il y a
entre guerre à simov que l'on a
d'ailleurs pas vu alors guirassimov on
rate le chef de en gros de l'opération
maintenant spéciale on peut dire en
Ukraine et bien il était absent pour à
se défiler et depuis des lustres depuis
pratiquement que Prigogine est en basse
il ne cesse d'insulter guerre à simov il
est par contre en très bonne relation
avec un autre militaire qui est agent
pratiquement qui sert de la il a fallu
que l'armée russe instaure entre lui et
le chef d'état-major russe un
intermédiaire on a on n'avait jamais vu
ça donc l'homme est un électron libre
dont se servent Vladimir Poutine et à
mon avis le jour il sera trop mal aussi
c'est électrolyse sera aussi celui que
l'on pourra utiliser pour expliquer des
tas de choses pour l'instant
Vladimir Poutine joue de cette rivalité
constante bon et Prigogine a toujours
parlé comme ça depuis qu'il existe ce
discours là c'est le discours qu'il n'a
cessé d'employer
même le cuisinier disait-on de Vladimir
Poutine il y a pas de grands
supplémentaires il y a pas assez c'est
c'est une sorte de jeu entre Poutine et
Prigogine il s'en sert c'est ça il y a
deux choses qui sont hyper intéressantes
je trouve c'est premièrement l'image
qu'on a là de yefghani prigogne qui est
en tenue treillis qui porte une
un pull-over et l'image de Sergei en
uniforme alors pardon c'est le ministre
de la Défense russe qui en uniforme
d'apparat ça n'est pas un militaire
originellement mais il est quand même en
uniforme d'apparat c'est un communiquant
qui arrive dans une limousine au 9 mai
11 ans à l'humilitaire et les troupes
donnent déjà du hourra ce fameux hourra
que vous avez coupé au montage et on n'a
pas encore on n'a pas entendu on n'a pas
entendu la troupe absolument répondre
qui est aussi un effet psychologique
pour nous qu'on soit clair le but aussi
de voir des milliers d'hommes hurlés ou
rares c'est drôle parce nous voyons le
sujet je me suis dit tiens on n'entend
pas la t'as pas la foule des soldats
réagir mais quand sergueil arrive on
entend déjà les hourra alors qu'un
ministre qui est pas militaire mais qui
est en costume d'apparade qui arrive
glorieux et le but est aussi de remettre
en selle le ministre par rapport à
prigogne qui a été si dur ces derniers
jours et il arrive sous les houras alors
on sait que les opérations sont quand
même pas extraordinaires mais est-ce
qu'il est-ce qu'il reste sous contrôle
c'est le deuxième point je trouve
absolument fascinant c'est qu'en fait
Vladimir Poutine il y a une raison pour
laquelle les compagnies privées sont
militaires privées sont interdites en
Russie c'est parce qu'ils ont peur
depuis les années 90 que les oligarques
qui sont des hommes extrêmement riches
dans une situation de politique
incertaine pour le moins puissent se
créer une armée privée et prendre le
pouvoir c'est très simple et Vladimir
Poutine en refusant ça en refusant aussi
de mobiliser la troupe parce qu'il a pas
confiance dans le peuple il a pas envie
de dire qu'en fait il y a autant de
pertes immobilisent finalement une armée
privée qui est illégale pour aller faire
sur le front se battre et finalement
qu'est-ce qu'il fait et ben c'est un
oligarque Prigogine est un oligarque qui
a une armée privée qui a même
l'autorisation d'aller dans les prisons
se servir enfin plus maintenant mais
enfin tout de même et qui maintenant
fait de la politique parce qu'en fait de
dire la guerre se passe mal il y a rien
de plus politique enfin genre il y a
rien de plus sensible politiquement et
puis dernier oui
il a osé dire quelque chose qui n'avait
encore jamais dit préconis il a attaqué
l'état l'État est responsable il est
très proche de Poutine en disant ça
c'est la première fois où il parle de
l'État il a dit il est généreux sont
responsables et aujourd'hui l'État n'est
pas capable de dire
est-ce que il masque pas aussi un peu
son son échec à lui puisque il y avait
l'hypothèse qui puisse livrer à Poutine
la prise de darkmouth avant ce 9 mai bon
bah ça ça n'est pas le cas donc est-ce
que il y a pas une part de gesticulation
on parle de guerre internationale pour
masquer cet échec aura pour le coup il y
a peut-être une différence de degré mais
pas de nature il y a vraiment rien de
nouveau sous le soleil il a toujours eu
un rôle ambivalent on parlait du dehors
et du dedans s'agissant des raisons qui
servent l'une et l'autre en matière de
de relation internationale en
l'occurrence à chaque fois c'est un coup
dedans c'est-à-dire vers la Russie et
puis un coup dehors bah contre l'Ukraine
honnêtement sur le plan tactique
l'emploi de ces milices Wagner c'est pas
ce qu'il y a donné moins bons résultats
sur le terrain à backmouth voilà et si
finalement c'est l'idiot ça je vous
laisse juge mais utile de de Poutine
c'est bien parce que il y a quand même
une certaine efficacité opérationnelle
sur le terrain malgré tout et c'est bien
pour ça qu'il compose avec lui et qu'il
est en situation un petit peu de faire
sa diva d'une certaine manière et il
faut ajouter que il est pas exclu qui
nourrissent des ambitions politiques et
donc par conséquent il y a une double
loyauté mais qu'il a aussi n'est pas
nouvelle donc on arrive à une situation
où effectivement par déclaration
interposée d'ailleurs ça a de quoi
laisser perplexe une milice mais un peu
à genoux un pouvoir étatique j'ai
observé ça ces derniers jours ça m'a
laissé un peu pantois bon qui est des
milices et des sociétés militaires
privées qui est des actions sur le
terrain et qui entretiennent un lien
fort avec des états c'est pas l'apanage
de la Russie quand on parle de
Blackwater d'aliberton c'est pas
vraiment des sociétés qui ont des
relations avec la Russie mais que ce
soit qui a un tel traitement sur le plan
public et que ce soit par déclaration
interposée comme ça il y a un côté un
peu gran guignol ça effectivement c'est
particulier voilà alors je propose à
Audrey oui c'est un homme d'affaire il
fait du business et peut-être il donne
en train de perdre les moyens de perdre
un peu d'argent en
Ukraine alors qu'il pourra en gagner
beaucoup plus en Afrique je simplifie
peut-être un peu mais il y a sans doute
un peu de ça on va continuer de parler
de ces millise Wagner avec Audrey metaz
bonsoir Audrey pour nous expliquer qu'il
y a plusieurs résolutions qui qui
concernent l'Ukraine et une qui concerne
la ministre Wagner qui était examinée
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée oui une
proposition transpartisane qui vise à
appeler la France et l'Union européenne
à inscrire le groupe militaire privé
Wagner sur la liste des organisations
terroristes les députés estiment que les
activités de Wagner cible délibérément
les civils pour avoir un gain politique
ce que l'on peut considérer comme du
terrorisme Thomas si la mélisse venait à
être inscrite sur cette liste cela
permettrait aux autorités européennes et
à leurs partenaires de lui imposer des
mesures de contrôle et de plus amples
sanctions donc ça c'est pour la
résolution à l'Assemblée et au Sénat oui
il y en a une autre au Sénat le but de
cette proposition de résolution portée
par André gatolin le sénateur de la
majorité présidentielle c'est de
dénoncer les transferts forcés massifs
d'enfants
Ukrainiens par la Fédération de Russie
on sait qu'il y en aurait au moins 19000
mais le chiffre pourrait être 10 fois
supérieur Thomas des enfants qui
auraient notamment été confiés par leurs
parents aux autorités russes on les
provinces du don-basse pour leur faire
fuir la guerre mais qui ne seraient pas
rentrer alors on sait très peu de choses
sur ce qui leur advient mais le pouvoir
de Moscou ne cache pas son désir de
russifier ses enfants recueillis dans
des circonstances floues un sujet dont
on a parlé assez tardivement chez nous
en France à peu près au mois d'août 2022
et qui pourtant pourrait constituer un
élément important parce que le
déplacement forcé constitue un crime de
génocide les sénateurs appellent donc
les autorités ukrainiennes à recensé ses
enfants disparus et pour information le
Sénat a adopté cette résolution à
l'unanimités c'est essentiellement
symbolique c'est politique l'objectif
c'est surtout de mettre le débat au cœur
de l'actualité de pousser peut-être les
gouvernements à agir dans le cas des
enfants déportés il peut y avoir une
autre visée écoutez pierre Rayman il est
secrétaire de l'association pour
l'Ukraine pour leur liberté et la nôtre
ces prises de position ne vont pas du
jour au lendemain faire revenir les
enfants il en faut malheureusement
beaucoup plus pour faire céder un
dictateur totalitaire comme Vladimir
Poutine mais elles exercent une pression
celle-ci aujourd'hui s'exerce
conjointement avec les mandats de la
Cour pénale internationale et plus les
pouvoirs politiques européens agissent
en ce sens plus ils vont augmenter la
pression sur la Fédération de Russie qui
malgré tout est mise au ban deviennent
des parias de la communauté
internationale sur cette question des
enfants alors pour le sénateur André
gatelin que j'ai pu contacter et qu'a
porter la résolution pour lui c'est
aussi un autre moyen de parler en France
de cette guerre salle je cite à une
opinion politique qui se lasse face à un
conflit qui dure maintenant depuis plus
d'un entonnoir merci Audrey Butters pour
toutes ces informations va on va ouvrir
un nouveau chapitre dans ce débat il
nous reste un quart d'heure il y a
encore beaucoup de thèmes à aborder
j'aurais qu'on parle de du rôle de de
l'Europe avec un premier élément la
réaction du chancelier allemand
aujourd'hui là aussi ce 9 mai à attirer
beaucoup de réactions évidemment il
affiche sa fermeté face à la Russie
à Moscou Poutine fait défiler ses
soldats ses chars et ses missiles ne
nous laissons pas intimider par une
telle démonstration de force restons
ferme dans notre soutien à l'Ukraine
aussi longtemps que nécessaire
Émilie depuis l'invasion de l'Ukraine
par son voisin russe on peut dire que le
sentiment européen grandit oui alors on
sait que Ursula funder Leyen était
aujourd'hui à Kiev pour afficher son
soutien évidemment sans faille à
l'Ukraine alors que Poutine comme on le
disait s'activait pour la commémoration
de la victoire sur l'Allemagne nazie
mais la présidente de la Commission
européenne était aussi là bien sûr pour
marquer la Journée de l'Europe le 9 mai
le moment est important puisque zellens
qui vient de faire passer un décret pour
dire que son pays célèbre aussi cette
journée de l'Europe et renonce donc à la
tradition soviétique alors ce sentiment
pro européen alors de l'Ukraine en effet
avec cette invasion l'Europe est revenue
au devant de la scène des événements au
ravivé ce sentiment pré-européen une
enquête a été menée en avril mai 2022
déjà auprès d'étudiants européens qui
montraient que ce soutien à l'Union
européenne était à son plus haut niveau
depuis 2007 en gros avec ce conflit les
attitudes pro-européennes se sont
renforcés et alors pour surfer sur cette
vague favorable dans une lettre qui a
été publiée aujourd'hui sur Twitter à
l'occasion toujours de la Journée de
l'Europe Emmanuel Macron a fait le bilan
des apports de l'Europe dont le rôle
incontournable de l'Europe dans le
conflit
ukrainien notre réponse commune face à
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie
fera date dit-il et aujourd'hui avec
notre aide l'Ukraine résiste et par son
propre courage ira jusqu'à la victoire
l'Europe hier parfois critiquée pour sa
lenteur et son éloignement agit vite et
fort en solidarité et dans la décennie
qui vient notre robe va nous permettre
de relever les défis de l'avenir alors
dans cette longue en avant aussi tous
les autres bienfaits de l'Europe en
termes de technologie d'innovation de
transition écologique bref on a
l'impression qu'on retrouve un petit peu
le candidat Emmanuel Macron de 2017 qui
avait dansé cardons un projet très
ambitieux pour l'Europe qu'il avait un
peu perdu au début de son quinquennat
jusqu'à la crise covid en fait et les
premiers déboires autour des masques je
pense que vous en souvenez des vaccins
et finalement ça a relancé son envie
avec quelques succès pas seulement
Macron évidemment c'était européen je
parle du grand plan d'investissement
européen et puis évidemment la
distribution des vaccins le l'autre
témoignage de ce retour en force de
l'Europe c'est la proposition de loi qui
était discutée aujourd'hui de
renaissance du groupe Renaissance qui
vise à imposer le drapeau européen aux
côtés du drapeau français sur le fronton
des mairies mais ça c'est pas gagné il
faut effectivement on a vu quelques voix
qui s'est élevaient cette réhabilitation
de l'Europe plutôt une bonne nouvelle
pour vous je pense que cette ambiance
pré-européenne elle repose de toute
façon sur de véritables atouts qu'a
démontré l'Europe durant ces crises
qu'on a traversé et qu'on traverse
encore mais attention peut-être à
l'extrême inverse c'est-à-dire à ne plus
pouvoir supporter la critique sur
l'Europe car si l'Union européenne s'est
montré plutôt réactive et efficace avec
un petit bémol sur le côté puissance
géopolitique ça ça reste à démontrer
mais en gros elle réagit surtout en
période de crise covid
Ukraine elle a très bien réagi qu'est-ce
qu'il en sera pour la suite est-ce que
l'Europe à la capacité de continuer à
évoluer à se transformer même dans des
moments plus paisibles alors on va pas
souhaiter des crises à répétition juste
pour faire avancer l'Europe mais
peut-être qu'on peut espérer que que cet
élan dramatique qui est dû à cette garde
dramatique sera durable en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on souhaite je voudrais
qu'on parle de la Patricia lemonnière de
la la procédure de d'intégration de
l'Ukraine avancée que ça poserait des
difficultés notamment vis-à-vis des pays
qui demandent à intégrer l'Union
européenne depuis depuis plusieurs
années est-ce que l'Ukraine pourrait
bénéficier d'un d'une procédure
accélérée en quelque sorte pour service
rendu alors vous avez
deux tendances dans l'Europe là pour le
coup elle est pas très unie pour cet
instant il y a ceux qui aimeraient une
processus accéléré en quelque sorte en
disant que l'on va beaucoup aider
l'Ukraine dans cette phase de guerre
pour faire en sorte qu'elle passe plus
rapidement les différents chapitres
parce que il y a un très nombre un grand
nombre de chapitres qu'elle doit en gros
qui sont des conditions d'adhésion donc
il faut que chaque fois elle elle
remplisse les conditions d'adhésion ça
c'est très long et donc certains
poussent à cette accélération une autre
partie de l'Europe sur laquelle dans
laquelle seront j'ai plutôt la France
dans un premier temps pensait que le
processus serait beaucoup plus lent et
qu'il fallait prendre son temps et on
voit très bien enfin de toute façon dans
un premier temps à partir du moment où
un pays est accepté comme candidat il y
a déjà des tas de choses qui sont faites
pour l'aider c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
gens qui sont envoyés pour les former
pour accélérer etc alors il y a des ces
choses là c'est c'est cet effort là que
peut faire l'Europe peut-être
effectivement démultiplier pour
l'Ukraine mais il n'y aura pas
d'adhésion tant qu'il y aura la guerre
et donc toute la vraie question qui se
pose aujourd'hui s'il n'y a qu'un cessez
le feu une nouvelle ligne de front mais
l'adhésion elle est reportée au
calendrier grec et donc en fait tout
dépend de la volonté
ukrainienne et russe de faire la paix et
les Ukrainiens c'est quitter le
territoire que vous que vous occupez
depuis 2014 et voir même quitter
l'ukrain donc je veux dire on en est
pour l'instant à l'heure où je vous
parle on en est très loin alors reste à
savoir cette offensive
ou contre-offensive
ukrainienne je vous propose d'écouter
une réaction peut-être autour des
conditions nécessaires avant de la
déclencher en écoute le président
zenenski aujourd'hui
nous avons discuté de la question clé la
rapidité d'approvisionnement et de
livraison de ces munitions on en a déjà
besoin sur le champ de bataille
alors je vais vous poser non je vous
pose pas la question c'est pourquoi
parce qu'on voulait oppose dans chaque
émission de télé depuis ouradio depuis
depuis des semaines
qu'est-ce qui se passe en ce moment j'ai
interrompais quoi est-ce que parce que
là j'écoute Zelenski qui dit rapidité
d'approvisionnement livraison de ces
munitions ils sont en train de stocker
des des armes en prévision de la
contre-offensive qu'on est dans quelle
phase en fait la livraison des chars
d'assaut
et aussi des Migs slovaque a pris du
temps parce que les Russes n'ont pas
spécialement envie que ce matériel
arrive sur le front
l'entraînement y compris la mobilisation
et l'entraînement de nouvelles troupes
qu'on dit troupes de choc
de plusieurs dizaines de milliers à prix
du temps et il faut accommoder les
matériels et les hommes les transporter
sur le front tout ça dans un secret
maximal ce qui n'est pas facile et comme
vous l'indiquez effectivement l'effet de
surprise dans une opération de ce genre
est important il y a des conditions
météorologiques il y a des conditions
politiques également qui importe de
prendre en compte fondamentalement on ne
sait pas quand la question est de savoir
est-ce que cette opération sera une
opération majeure est-ce que sera une
opération qui touchera la Crimée comme
les rues soi-même le laisse penser en
construisant des défenses considérables
en Crimée
il est probable que les Ukrainiens
comptent sur un enfoncement ou plusieurs
enfancements du front qui soient
substantiels et je crois que le
président zenenski disait aujourd'hui
que
l'important c'était de couper même la
retraite des Russes pas pour la retraite
en tant que telle mais de couper les
lignes d'approvisionnement en fait pour
créer une panique sur le front avec une
stratégie du brouillard de guerre Julien
Theron c'est c'est quoi ces multiplier
les petites opérations claires
en fait la question d'abord c'est de
savoir ce que l'on cherche à faire en
stratégie il y a les fins et les moyens
faut toujours articuler les deux donc la
première question c'est le pourquoi et
donc là on parlait des divisions de
l'Europe il y a deux versions possibles
en substance soit vous considérez que le
combat en Ukraine est vital pour
l'Europe parce que lui a la Russie après
l'Europe envahirait les pays baltes et
puis toute l'Europe et auquel cas il
faut effectivement que le mot victoire
soit rempli
le point de revenir dans les frontières
de 91 avec la Crimée et le Dombas mais
pour ça il faut mettre beaucoup plus de
moyens et dans ce cas là il faut
véritablement être capable de mener une
campagne une conférencie qui soit
véritablement ce qu'on appelle multichan
multi-domaines c'est-à-dire investir
toutes les dimensions de la guerre et
pour faire court parce qu'on n'a pas le
temps il faut en premier lieu des succès
sur la dimension aérospatiale pour
qu'ensuite on puisse avoir espéré avoir
un succès sur le plan terrestre
aerospatial dans héros spatial il y a
spatial
en début de crise s'il y avait pas eu
Starlink on serait pas là vous ce soir
vous et moi on en parlerait même plus
voilà donc succès c'est un réseau de
communication connexion spatiale pour
pouvoir organiser le commandement et le
contrôle des opérations pour se parler
sur le terrain c'est fondamental donc
dimension aérospatiale et évidemment
aussi dimension aéronautique avec une
campagne aérienne Bontin pour taper
derrière les forces derrière la ligne
ennemi donc pour l'instant il y a que
deux pays si je ne me trompe nous n'y
sommes évidemment
pas et donc cette version haute de fait
ce disqualifie de fait et il y a une
autre version j'allais dire qui est pour
une victoire mais non pas une victoire
submergente mais une victoire dans la
Résistance qui serait exclusivement une
dimension terrestre et dans ce cas-là il
y a trois préceptes qui prévalent en
stratégie c'est un la surprise et
l'initiative on en a parlé donc où et
quand ça on sait pas est-ce que ce sera
au nord au sud donc je reviens le
brouillard de guerre de tout à l'heure
reviens maintenant au brouillard de
guerre la concentration des moyens et là
aussi on revient au brouillard de guerre
il faut être capable de concentrer les
moyens faut pas faire du tapot autour ce
qui veut dire de mobiliser les forces et
de les organiser et donc il faut être
capable de ne pas être lisible dans
cette façon de bouger les forces les
blindés l'artillerie l'infanterie or là
les services russes on peut le reprocher
beaucoup de choses mais enfin c'est pas
les moins bons services du monde donc
pour arriver à faire ça sans être
lisible c'est exemple voilà et puis il
faut être capable de durer c'est être et
durer et donc là c'est la question de la
logistique et c'est la question des
munitions et c'est la question de la
météo aussi est-ce que ça permettra avec
ces questions des de la boue cette
fameuse raspoutidza là est-ce que la
météo permettra de mener des actions
dans la durée et des factions compte des
actions continuent et ce qu'on sera pas
obligé d'attendre pour pouvoir mener
cette contre-offensive et donc non
seulement la dimension aérospatiale sera
pas investie donc la version haute est
pas possible mais la version terrestre
reste quand même entourée d'énormément
de questions et tout le sujet une fois
qu'on a eu le pourquoi le quoi et le
comment c'est véritablement dans quel
but infinie car là on ne parle que de la
dimension militaire la dimension
politique c'est arriver aussi fort que
possible à la table des négociations et
donc avoir un ancrage fort et donc là
l'enjeu c'est véritablement plus que la
contrepensive elle-même je finis juste
d'être capable dans le cadre de la
dimension de la guerre cognitive de
faire croire à une contre-offensive puis
on sait que en stratégie toute puissance
qui se réalise sa moindrie toute
puissance qui se réalise à moindre idée
donc il faut être capable de faire
croire à cette puissance là parce que le
jour où cette guerre sera livrée de fait
elle a toutes les chances de décevoir le
brouillard de la guerre fait que le
premier mort du champ de bataille c'est
le plan et qu'ensuite faut composer et
on fait on part avec de grands principes
et on revient avec nos propres moyens et
donc ça peut décevoir éventuellement et
dans la perspective de ces négociations
il faut arriver fort c'est négociations
quelque chose qui est passé sous le SCOP
dernièrement c'est que le divin ski a
parlé pour la première fois depuis deux
ans avec le président chinois
de paix passe sous notre scope à nous
pas sous votre stop à vous et il s'est
dit beaucoup de choses il s'est dit
notamment que le président zeninski
souhaitait des relations bilatérales
renforcées avec la Chine et il a nommé
dans la foulée un ambassadeur en Chine
donc si je vous entends pardon nous
interrompre quelques minutes et jouer
avec chacun puisse avoir un mot de
conclusion Patricia Lemonnier je
commence avec vous donc
de cette de cette contre-offensive
dépend une éventuelle ouverture de
discussion et négociation c'est ce que
je comprends bah c'est ce que tout le
monde dit effectivement enfin
actuellement ce qui est intéressant de
voir c'est que justement pour se
brouillard pour alimenter ce fameux
brouillard dont vous venez de parler
plus personne n'accès peut les
journalistes même les ONG n'ont accès
dans les zones de front c'est-à-dire
c'est totalement maintenant verrouillé
et quand on rentre ça fait maintenant à
peu près trois semaines un mois que
c'est que toute cette partie là est
verrouillée et les les Russes ont des
systèmes effectivement d'écoute mais qui
sont beaucoup moins quand même
performants que que le côté ukrainien
donc les Ukrainiens actuellement tente
de d'envoyer des leurs en quelque sorte
et ses jus pour justement créer cet
effet de surprise et cet effet de
surprise ne marchera que s'il y a des
leurres ne marchera ici comme vous
l'avez dit que s'il y a suffisamment de
troupes et que si effectivement parce
qu'on ne parle pour ne sont que
d'offensif terrestre que si le front est
enfoncé en plusieurs points et si enfin
l'armée russe n'est pas capable de
résister et on sait j'en finis par là
que toutes les armées qui sont positions
de résistance subissent moins de pertes
que celles qui attaque et je termine par
l'une des annonces de la journée les
États-Unis Joe Biden un milliard 200
millions de dollars supplémentaires pour
renforcer notamment pas seulement mais
notamment la défense aérienne de
l'Ukraine geste fort évidemment
symbolique en ce en ce 9 mai mais
pourquoi refuse-t-il de livrer les
avions de chasse dans ce contexte
général ça prend beaucoup de temps de
former des pilotes
ça les fait passer dans une organisation
sur les appareils de type F16 a priori
ce qui ce qui serait un peu long et ce
qui engage des processus un peu
différents ceci dit avoir la maîtrise de
l'air c'est aussi par les défenses
entières aériennes ce qui permet même
s'il y a pas beaucoup d'aéronefs de
couvrir la scène et de ce point de vue
là depuis le 24 février 2022 l'Ukraine a
fait des progrès absolument
considérables avec plusieurs rideaux de
défense entière ce qui permet plus du
tout au russe de se balader comme il
voulait sur le territoire ukrainien et
donc même si l'Ukraine n'a pas une armée
de l'air considérable ça lui permet
aussi en tout cas suffisamment d'appuyer
au sol et de pouvoir percer peut-être
pas effectivement c'est pas l'Air Force
américaine mais enfin ça n'est pas rien
non plus merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat je rappelle le
titre de vos livres Julie interrompt le
Pacte des autocrates publiés aux
éditions Robert Laffont et Jérôme klech
la prospective stratégique apparaître le
24 mai aux éditions Hermann merci à tous
encore une fois